c'est emmanuel macron qui qui mènent
tous alexandre évacué sain de en marche
effectivement le cas ça n'est qu'une
marionnette est un peu la marionnette
idéal l'homme de main le plus le plus
discipliné pour macro et si l' on vit
aussi que castanet un resto au parlement
c'est aussi pour retenir tout simplement
sa majorité donc je vois voilà ce que ça
révèle ce qui est paradoxal
effectivement c'est qu'on nous vendait
le nouveau monde et comme le dit
françois xavier bellamy dans figaro va
m'emmener dans le nouveau monde
politiciens là bien plus après moi ça me
choque pas je ne croyais pas du tout à
la démocratie participative et à
l'horizontalité qui nous étaient vendus
mais ce qu'ils aiment ce qui est amusant
c'est qu'on est finalement dans un
fonctionnement très vème république
presque gaulliste ou schule le parti est
une machine de guerre au service d'un
homme
emmanuel macron ce qui me plaît moi
c'est plutôt le cérémonial que j'ai vu
pour l'investiture de castanet on avait
l'impression que c'était le nouvel apple
castaner et qu'on était si on faisait
des ciels vie fillon agitaient des
pancartes verte est donc là on se dit
qu'on est dans un parti qui va pas
beaucoup réfléchir et qui sera dans un
côté post moderne comme ça qu'il ya plus
rien à voir avec la politique avec un
grand p
mais pour revenir sur le